[Music]
Kim Kardashian and Kanye West welcome
baby number three I'm very happy the
pair's new little girl was born via
surrogacy and Kim recently opened up to
ete about her growing family what has
been the adjustment sort of going
through this with a surrogate this time
you know it's really different anyone
that says or thinks it's just the easy
way out is completely wrong I think it's
so much harder to go through it this way
coz you're not really in control and you
know obviously you pick someone that you
completely trust and that you have a
really good bond and relationship with
but it's still knowing that I was able
to carry my first two babies and not you
know my baby now that is hard for me so
it's definitely a harder experience than
I anticipated just in the control area
are the kids excited they are excited I
mean I don't know if they don't feel it
as much because I don't they don't see
my big belly and probably hear me
complaining every two seconds so though
but we do talk about it a lot so a
little bit they will I think they're
really excited I think my son I don't
know how he's gonna react because he
doesn't get it yet but my daughter's
really excited
[Music]
you